this is a production of Cornell
University
so we'll go through this I'm going to
try to go you know why are we doing this
some of the history how this all got uh
going uh and what's going on right now
and finally I'll talk a little bit about
how this is being done the kind of
techniques so when you see the map you
say well how are these people making
these Maps nowadays
so why do we do Global mapping and so
the reason I'm saying this we have now
global models there's a lot of global
modeling and I gave a good example here
of a very popular
model there's a lot of demand for Global
assessments so you you see stocks status
of the world soil resources where you're
trying to compare countries approaches
and so forth and so you want some
consistent Global databases uh and it
has to be of course uh spatially
explicit because you you would like now
not only to have something let's say
country by country uh you'd like to
really know where things are happening
so you'd like to have a global a global
mapping effort so why not combine
National Maps that's be the obvious
thing we have a lot of countries in the
world
and I'm talking now specifically about
soil mapping soil resource mapping uh
many areas are not mapped at all people
have hardly been there large areas of
the world uh maybe a little bit of
reconnaissance but actually no
systematic mapping they're actually not
very well understood that at any scale
they're not mad
many other are with poor quality Maps
there are countries where there have
been mapping programs but the soil
survey organization has fallen into
disrepair uh the maps might be very old
and done with poor techniques poor Geo
reference
many areas don't have the key property
so for your model you might want bulk
density you might want carbon stock you
might want the the
salinity something about salinity and
it's not there in that database so even
when you have the map of that area you
don't have the key property that you're
interested in for your model
and finally if you look at the national
Maps obviously there's huge
inconsistencies in methods that are used
for survey definitions uh mapping
standards and so forth and uh this is a
you know this is well known
and so we had a case of a number of
years ago it was very interesting case
in between the Netherlands and Germany
which are both very well mapped
countries and it is a project where this
was maybe already 30-40 years ago it
took an area where partisan the
Netherlands parties in Germany and the
surveyors from the Dutch did both areas
and the surveyors of Germany did the
both areas and both maps are published
and you see uh both are highly
experienced mappers but the maps look
very different now if you would go and
use them for practical purposes they'd
probably be okay but you can't just
Stitch those Maps together and they they
prove that with that program and that's
what seemed very highly developed and
the competent Soul survey organizations
this is an example of what happens when
the FAO tries to stitch together
National Maps now the FAO the pertinent
agriculture organization has the mandate
to work with countries and so they like
to work with each country which makes
perfect sense and so they like to do
their projects from the bottom up and
here we have two countries and we're
looking at their soil organic carbon
stock
and which two countries are we looking
at here
I could in two languages
so this is our these are our these are
our Canadian friends up here that seem
to have a lot of carbon going on here
and here we have the line here we are in
Montana and we look like we've
completely depleted our resources now
I'm not exactly sure that's true or the
Canadian Prairie Farmers so much better
farmers in our planes farmers in America
I'm asking you Tony uh I would say yes
but
and now now let's go over to Asia so we
have a bunch of countries here what
countries are we see here
yeah
Nepal is here
come on you guys you can't go there
Bangladesh
it's only one of those anymore
so not only are there big differences
but I can seriously Bhutan apparently
has done a some kind of soil mapping
project where there's a lot of detail
and you can see here in the in this at
least this part of India in this project
I should say this is what they get so
this is the problem with trying to deal
with uh with the stitched together Maps
so that's why we're thinking we want
Global drivers
this also calls a little bit in question
if you would use a national product
is reliable so what happened
back in 1961 and a lot of you are we're
not going back then back in Cold War
days there was a lot of attention
between uh Soviet block and the Western
block but they managed to get together
and the amazing version of what we call
uh pedo politics pedo per pedology you
know for soils a project was done by the
FAO to make a soil map of the world
involving the scientists from all the
continents in a very collaborative
project
and so this was done at a scale of one
to five million which they felt was
possible with its all knowledge they had
this was very broadly defined soil
classes but at least it was somewhat
useful and back in 1986 silver digitized
this and for many years this was your
soil map of the world a digital soil map
would raster cells of half degree and
that's the only thing that was available
but it was a really good initiative and
this is a example of a map they're all
they've all been scanned they're all
online and available which I linked
before and I won't make you pick the
countries up here but this is a great
lakes area and here we have Lake
Victoria so we've Uganda Kenya or
Orlando already and over here we have
DRC and South Sudan and what you could
see was the major difference in the uh
the detail that was available now Kenya
had a very active soil survey the Uganda
where the Katina concept was developed
actually
and with Rwanda Burundi I have a special
connection because my PhD Professor here
Armand vamabeki and he's a Belgian and
when he was a young scientist in the
late 1940s these were bells and
protectorates and he did the soil
surveys of Rwanda Burundi when he was
before he came here he was my PhD
Professor Ben later in the 1980s he had
many good stories to tell about this
together though two countries are about
the size of the Netherlands but you see
the intern systems and also you look at
some of these lines that are obviously
just guesses now there's some knowledge
there so that was a person
this is an idea of the soil Legend and
they were just these overall classes
based on uh Soul Genesis and they had
subclasses this was early General
this then this has been digitized uh as
an available here as as we shaped files
and so forth they have now actually gone
and digitized that mass and they're not
being updated but you can get that if
you want
then the next big initiative was the
harmonized world soil database this was
between FAO and yasso which is the inner
Institute for systems analysis in Vienna
and with the place I work in the
Netherlands now District rules all
information Chinese Academy of Sciences
and jrc
and this now is now about equivalent
more or less 150 000 scale it's a 30
degree
in this case they said well we're going
to just make soil in two layers this is
soil we have some but the difference
here was finally we had a map of soil
properties there are some estimates in
these grid cells of the soil property
values and you can see the kind of
you know this is a list of their
properties
this is what it looks like in good part
of the world
see if anyone can identify the distance
so this is 19 here this is the PRC and
these are the soil type codes you can
see they have a cell type and then
you can then go to those and get
something like topsoil sand proportion
so you get not a bad MAP at this
resolution unfortunately not every part
of the world can participated in one
group that would not participate was an
RCS in the United States the map of the
United States I was embarrassed to show
New York State shows in two colors
they sort of have any of this line
between the Appalachian Plateau and the
Ontario plane attack goes like this so
uh yeah they just didn't cooperate the
Americans are very inward looking
thank you
anyway no but this is a good resource
where it's where it is and what I just
found out just last week and I haven't
had a chance to get um evaluate this but
the version 2 is just released and they
now have seven layers instead of two uh
they have very new data sources uh
they've added some properties here
especially things like CN ratio aluminum
saturation that can really be uh really
useful and so the idea here you can see
it's objective
so Global aggregate logical zoning so
this should be nice I I haven't uh I
haven't yet evaluated these were done
from Legacy products expert knowledge
and so forth not the digital soil
mapping techniques I'll talk about later
then there was a project uh which was a
challenge from our own Pedro Sanchez and
many of you may know him we have Cornell
graduate and then worked has moved up
into the world and as the world was rise
at some point and he challenged Us in
2008 I'm speaking of the soil mapping
community
and he's a soul fertility management
person but he said look I I want these
soil Maps so that I can go well he said
I want to be go anywhere in Malawi on
any Farmer's field and you tell me why
fertilizer recommendations he says well
dream on this is not going to happen but
we can do better
um they got the Gates Foundation and
Jefferson got involved so the gates got
the call clearly
the idea was to have Regional notes
working to one standard and then they
would put them together with since there
would be one standard we would have one
map the standards were successfully
developed and these are now very widely
used also in National products
however the project failed totally
because they never thought it would be
impossible to make regional notes North
America worked well by this time nrcs
was in the game and got interested in
digital soil mapping and so already had
good relations with our colleagues in
Mexico and Canada and so North America
was all right South America more or less
a CI but in South Asia no country is
going to let their data go to one of the
other countries and the same thing
happened in East Asia so this failed as
a project but it had a good output which
were these specifications that were
worked on quite extensively and so if
you're going to make a digital soil
mapping knowledge of having
specifications very even thought out a
lot they're very easy to use
and I wanted to show some results for
the nodes that did work so you get an
idea of how this product will look here
is Australia
and these are some properties let's see
what I have a sand silk clay
and what is this lesson
can't see what D is but look at that so
this is all of Australia sand silk clay
and a very important factor that was
part of the standard that is now
possible with the digital soil mapping
techniques we're using is that you get
an uncertainty map at the same time as
part of the various techniques we use
for the soil manual
um and these are in this case is on a
relative scale expressed as a range of
the 90 competent intervals standardized
by the mean so it essentially says
what's the width of that interval
divided by the mean and you can see some
areas in this case of sand with very low
uncertainty but over here in Queensland
and the New South Wales look we have
some high under uncertainty and we also
see higher uncertainty for for silt and
Clay so it's very useful because what
you can now do is say which map which
parts of the map are not useful enough
for me I can decide on a level of
certainty this is also useful for going
out and taking more samples because
presumably these areas that are not so
represented well represented in your
models you have more information near
the model
so
that's a little bit of History so let's
talk about who's now making Global songs
um
now my uh I have uh I've retired from
the University event in the Netherlands
because we have of course retirement in
the Netherlands unlike the Cornell has
gone on forever and ever feel like it
comes and uh so then they very kindly
invited me to come here and
[Music]
which is associated with the universe
agricultural University but not part of
it is an independent Foundation that is
the world data center for soils and this
was set up pretty much at the same time
that the FAO had the project for the
world of the map saw a map of the world
in the 1960s
and the Dutch government the Ministry of
Foreign Affairs gives the core funding
for the idea was core funding for this
is the ideas to provide soil data for
the world and you can look at this and
we have a harmonized point database so
the idea is to collect points from all
the countries you can get them from
in whatever form these Point data sets
were given to you and then harmonize
them the best we can
put them in a database that's publicly
available that people can use for their
own projects
um
some data we get under the condition
that can't be shared outside so
unfortunately you can't see it but we
can use it for internal mapping projects
uh with that we are making a product
called soil grids which I'll show in a
minute which is a global soil extent map
so it's a consistent matter over the
whole world using as the basis our
harmonized soil database and if you have
any databases you'd like to contribute
you know feel free I was sent by the FDO
to Cambodia a few years ago to evaluate
a project at the gun and I I ran into
the went out to the AG experiment
station and I was talking with soil
scientists and he said yeah yeah the
Australians were here some time ago and
they made this database and
I just known to Houston so
I took it back and I look at and so we
wrote a memorandum I said this is great
when they had done like 850 points all
over Cambodia lto referenced all
analyzed
I don't know whatever happened to it in
Cambodia but anyway we wrote a
memorandum of understanding to the
ministry of Agriculture and they said
sure you can use this freely we took it
back it's now part of our database
that's the kind of thing you can do on
your travels across Seoul Point
databases can you let us know
so this is our idea consistent Point
data plus covariance which are
environmental factors we'll show you how
that works in a minute we get consistent
local maps and this is our little our
little data model here
we have our data providers
it was a data model we have our database
that we can use for soil grids and we
have some various services online
services so you can get all this stuff
just wanted to show the kind of data we
have so if you look here this is central
Africa and you can see we there's a lot
of work in Rwanda we have a lot of
access these are publicly available so
there's over a thousand sold profiles to
get through this right geo-referenced in
Rwanda uh Burundi
hardly any and that they're almost the
same size and of course you can see the
size of Congo
other countries there more we can't use
all of it but you can see the difference
in in Precision that you might have
uh here is in the in Europe which is
really so don't don't think this only
has to do with uh with the country's uh
you know week or so so the organizations
here we have our belgians and especially
our Swiss friends are doing a tremendous
amount of work in our the French are all
on strike or something
no actually the reason for that is the
French have this very strong privacy
laws that the location of the soil
sample cannot be given out to the public
which is very different in the United
States where we go I mean under the law
as it now stands the sole surveyors to
go out take a sample give the Geo
reference and it's publicly available
that goes back since President Lincoln
set up the USDA with the idea that would
all be up it would all be um
I guess you all knew that President
Lincoln set up the USDA started the
Transcontinental Railroad and there was
something else he did but I can't
remember quite what that was about
something else something else important
anyway uh but seriously they have a lot
of points so the French themselves can
make these very good maps where we can't
do that so
this is the problem with the with these
sorts of things
so our product is this we're using a
global soil map specifications and the
concept of how big will the pixel size
be uh is a contentious one
with the computer power we have now you
can make them happen 10 meters 20 meters
but do we have the data to support it
and we feel that this is actually really
pressing it to even go to this level
because of the quantity of data in the
world now our covariance
based on let's say remote sensing and
elevation models and so forth we have
those definers and find a resolution but
to make the map we're not confident so
we get five visible properties for
chemical properties
and we also were working on this is the
this world WRB is the world record space
for soil classification which is the FAO
system the International System now soil
taxonomies used in the United States and
in some other countries like Venezuela
Thailand but in India but the world
system is used internationally but that
was an older product and we are having a
lot of trouble making these Maps
categories so the methods we use these
random course I'll show in a minute they
work well for the continuous properties
but for these classified properties with
32 classes and many subclasses we have
not had a lot of success but we had one
in a previous version we have an
outdated version that we used to look at
uh we generalize these products because
many modelers want a more General
product a land surface modeler they're
not going to look at something at a 250
meter scale
we want bigger scale so we can easily
generalize those
and it's available in lower pension
catalog and next week my my lucky
students in
in the 6200 course will be using these
layers out of Google eventually
so this is a picture and
but something about this we can't see
the country more this is this is our
friends in Canada here we are in Montana
okay here we have the you know here we
have the glacier partner and you notice
there's no border at all here it's one
model for the whole world so you know
this if this is good this is good and
you can see a much more consistent
picture here so you know we'll go
farther north we're getting more stops
we're getting more stocks in the higher
Mountains for example here in the
Rockies and so forth
um and uh you know when you get the
lower ones in the planes and so forth
I'm not saying it's all correct but we
now have a consistent path so if you
were doing some modeling in this area
between between the two countries that
are divided by just the parallel then
you would have a much more consistent
product
we also this is a little hard for you to
see here we also have the uncertainty
map in the same way that I showed you
the Australians so in fact the
uncertainty is higher here in some of
these areas
even within the plain area we have some
areas with a higher uncertainty this
comes out of the mapping process which
I'll explain in a minute
and this is something I had a little fun
with I took all the
soil properties and all the depths and I
did of course I just did some k-means
clustering and I said well do I see any
natural soil units coming out this is
this is a map of our lovely area here
um and the and I'm showing the uh
then the principle from home and saw
this and I'm showing these natural
clusters and you know it doesn't look
all that bad you know we see the the
endless mountains down here we've got
Ontario Plains here we are in Aurora you
can even see our lower level kind of
late derived soils here so that was
pretty interesting so this map was made
from a global map so it used all the
data in the world to map everywhere in
the world and all I did was take this
part out it covers this area and do the
K needs clustering and get this thing
out of it so if you're going in so one
of my take-home messages if you're going
to a new area that hasn't been back you
don't have a good soil Network you could
do this I guess I think I put this on my
website up for a member but technique
it's all in our of course and you'd get
at least a idea of kind of a general
zoning of your area according to the
soil Province so he's pretty I thought
this was actually pretty good this was
using Google events
and the white is because we don't we
don't map in the city in the water or in
the urban areas urban areas
another provider I want to mention is
FAO soil resources because they are as I
said an internationally mandated work on
this
there's a structure called the global
cell partnership and this has several
aspects it's a Cooperative effort
bringing in all the different countries
with the technical panel on soils they
have priorities for different years of
the soil to do many things as well as
mapping and the head of this is now one
of my was my masters back there in the
Netherlands the Bolivian guy Ronald
Vargas moved his way up over the years
they stitch together products but I want
to mention this even though I told you
that Stitch products were not
I have my problems with them because
they do show the whole world and it is
another approach to matching world and
here's an example again with us and
Canada
of what they call black soils this was a
fairly controversial product and they
said well
where are the their definition of black
soils it's not Champions and it's not
molosols it's a more general definition
of what they mean by black soils but
then they decided they wanted to make a
map because of all the interesting
carbon so they did this and again here
we have
the parallel right
49th parallel is right here between
Canada and the U.S if you realize Tony
we wanted 54 40 year fight you know hear
about that we just gave up
yeah
but anyway this is their product and so
they are making products so that's what
I wanted to point out more thematic
products license uh then here is uh so
colleagues of mine that uh really have a
tremendous work unfortunately these
websites are offline right now I wrote
to the Sean the guy of my contact and I
visited them in this group they used to
be you could see them bnu they used to
be at Beijing Normal University and the
whole group got recruited to someone at
10 University in Guangzhou and they have
these very nice global data sets
especially for hydraulic and thermal
parameters I'm going to write them again
Steve Miller come back online maybe
they'd change the address as a few weeks
ago it was working
um and this wanted to show away is the
main author there
so if you're working soil hydrology or
land surface models where you want
thermal properties of soil they've done
a lot of derived problems so they say
you know the thermal conductivity of the
soil that that kind of thing obviously
these are going to be somewhat difficult
products to make but they're working on
this and this all gridded and it was
freely that it is freely available when
the website
then another group and yet another of my
students was Tom hengel who's my PhD
student some years ago he worked at his
Rick and he was behind sawgrid's version
one and then he left to form his own
company
and they uh make mostly Regional amounts
because of demand and they work on
contract but they're very Innovative in
very sophisticated techniques they use
to make these maps and this is a map
that was done with an Africa product
project so much I'll show this uh and
this is for example a subtractable iron
I mean they they make models of 30
meters which I really doubt it shows a
lot of detail which I don't think is
really fair but anyway that's one of the
players
and you'll see there you'll see their
products they're also based
so
those are the people that are making the
global soil Maps now you know I
apologize you know I one I don't know
please let me know if you know about one
that I don't know about
and being curious I I'll later showed
the portal I have where I try to collect
all these things this one I'd like to
know about it for sure
so I'd like to take the last part here
10 minutes or so to talk about how are
these Maps being made now when I see
these maps I mean it's like how was this
map actually made obviously they didn't
go out there every meter Square in
central Africa and do this what was
going on
what that one way is to take Lego steps
so maps that have been made by
traditional methods showing polygons
um and these uh far so half of the world
hwsd and the United States the Sergo
products the way they're made the point
where maps have already been made
and somehow transforming those by decide
on a scale or a resolution in a legend
you make a common Legend and you
digitize them and use some kind of
harmonization that's the way the
harmonized world soil data was so they
had the line and polygon lines digitize
them
figured out a communal engine correlated
them and then rasterized it finally at
some scale of A1
you would then link this to your
database and the way you do that is you
would say well in this polygon it's
represented by this so in the United
States we have uh the dominant soil
Series in the polygon it's got an
official series description in the list
of properties and this is an example
from us I just want to show the way
these things might look
so here we have a soul map and here we
have the Tri-County Corner that are
under here by Courtney Hopkins in Tioga
County here we are Hammond Hill there
and you know in each of these polygons
this was done by manual methods we can
click on a point there we can get the
representative soil profile
and from that representative profile
they have some idea of what the problems
are there but those properties of course
would be inside everywhere that's
working with BBV wouldn't have the same
problem
but these aren't one way to make laws if
you go to many areas they don't have
these kind of maps you can't do badly so
the more common method now that's used
very widely is digital soil map and
the concept here is to go direct visible
so we're going to make a digital map
from the beginning only knowing from our
points so this idea was kicking around
around the late 1990s and 2000s and then
codified in this very good paper that uh
it really laid out the whole landscape
by Alex mcgraphy and Newman Elsa Santos
Brazil
is also he's Indonesian but he's been a
professor in Australia now so when she
was on the on sabbatical in Australia
they worked this out so what do we do
we have a geo-referenced head-on
observations you've got to start with
that so you know points do you know
where they are
and then you have the attributes there
so
when I add a point and I knew the soil
attribute I also know I can take remote
sensing images I can take climate Maps I
can take elevation models and terrain
derivatives I can take say the Night
Lights map to see how much uh human
activity there is can make a big stack
of these things and since I is that I
know those everywhere
from the point that I'm at I just go
stick a pin right through those and I
have any number of what we call
covariates that we think relate to the
soil property and that's the concept
there are a couple of methods and I I
guess I forgot I should have put this up
first
at a very small scale like in a field in
a field scale with lots of intense data
in a field like when we deal monitor or
something like that or very intense
sampling in the field you can use pure
geoseongestible methods such as cream
but that's not applicable over large
areas so in general we now use machine
learning methods
digital uh that random forests are quite
used but also some people use gradient
boosting or vector machines or neural
networks they all work the same way the
idea here is that the covariance
we've picked to represent so important
facts so we know that uh temperature
just to make an example has a large
effect on in the carbon budget right at
real high temperatures and low
temperatures moisture that kind of thing
position on the slope things that we
know from soil survey and from our
theory of soil formation should have
some relation now this is just an
empirical relationship you're not making
any kind of uh process model
so we make these empirical relations and
we then can build a random Forest that
goes from all these predictors to our
training data and see and then when we
have a new point
we just go into our random forest and we
run down our random forest and we make a
prediction now there are problems with
this which I'll mention in a minute but
this is since we know the covariance of
all the good cells
once we build a model at any grid cell
we now go to we know that covariate and
we can go down found that and make
prediction it so that's uh that's the
way things are now made
now why is it so popular
well it's easy rapid and cheap you just
need a big computer and you can even use
Google revention and you don't cost you
anything or very little
um very easy to do and but what is
important is we now have covariance that
we think are well related to the soils
and what I like a lot on gamma ray
emissions which unfortunately we don't
have over the whole world what Australia
has is and that's one of the reasons
they can make such good maps it tends to
be it turns out to be a lot of relation
to soil properties
um
you have good training materials so FAO
has done some history has done some so
it's a lot of the techniques have been
worked out there are scripts and more
invention scripts and so forth you can
the FAO made a very nice project on this
they have a lot of good training
materials so quite easy to get into this
um
and this is the net this is negative
this is why it's possible you don't need
to know anything
you know so you don't have to know
anything about soil a soil survey to do
this you don't have to have any feel for
the landscape you just do it and that's
why uh and you know and but the
advantage there is there's a lack of
trained mappers correlators and quality
Patrol many countries don't have an
organization at all or if they do it's
very underfunded
um and so you know you don't really you
don't really have an alternative so
um that's so that's one of the reasons
is popular you can go into a country and
then uh as I said underfunded or
non-existent so I'll certain
organizations so for example in Nepal of
the FAO did a training and Nepal only
had soil survey done in a few places but
they wanted a country the whole map the
country don't have the money to send
people out and do surveys all over the
place but they still made a map now how
good is that Matt that's another
question
so that's one of the reasons it's so
popular
um I won't spend much time in this we
have our observations and our covariance
we put them in this big what we call a
regression Matrix and there's a lot of
technical
technical deals here that we go through
the model fitting and
and uh the uh tuning and so forth and we
end up making the maps and the
uncertainties
this is an example of a celebration
I don't know if anyone recognizes this
area not too far from here
any pennsylvanians here
yes I know we have a Pennsylvania
where is this I'll give you a hints in
Pennsylvania
this is Lockhaven Lockhaven Pennsylvania
here Williamsport Pennsylvania over here
so yeah luckily and then
What lands ends
desert would be up here higher that's
yeah you're right that's going so this
is the Allegheny plateau and here we see
the particular sand and you see very
high sand contents up here in these sand
stones at the top of the Allegheny
plateaus so the soils form they're quite
Sandy right you get down here how these
are the famous Limestone valleys this is
actually got a great name it's called
the nipponos the nipponose valley and
back in my masters at Penn State I was
doing breathing and I had some trials
beautiful little Valley so you can see
these have very high clay content very
low stuff so it's not bad but look at
these things up here there's definitely
some artifacts I mean this this is not
right there's no way that all of a
sudden I mean I I know this area there's
no
Sandstone Oak drop or something that's
making this area this little one square
which is really high about right so
that's not right
so you see the problem we're doing this
mechanically
but all in all it's all right
uh so the model uncertainty I mentioned
is
um and so I just go I'll just point out
that you could refuse to map areas that
are too uncertain if you want to and
that's one of the big advantages of this
um to show you how bad the uncertainty
can be this is where our area here this
is our prediction of pH so soil grids
now remember this is being done with
models calibrating with data for the
whole world right not just from this
area so here's our pH we have we have a
rat down in about 4.5 secure floors up
here were around sevens so I'm not so
sure these areas up around the Portland
area are much lower pH study the hills
to the South I'm not sure I don't think
so I didn't check the value because we
have a little problem but this is not
bad right we're looking at PHS around
6.87 in Aurora we're looking at in our
Plateau zero fives and so
but but the uncertainty the five percent
quantile in the random Forest is giving
us values of three and a half year
don't drink that water
and then up in Aurora really you know
way low and look can we have saline salt
and the pH is above eight up in Aurora
no it can't happen this is what happens
with these models when you run it
through the trees this is what you get
so we we publicize these so you can
decide and and here's an area you think
you see the pattern but uh so the
quantile the uncertainty with the
predictions we have is verified
okay last thing is how you get these
things I have a site that I maintain for
many years first I was at the University
and then I moved into Israel when I went
there
um that I allowed the world databases
everything we have
everything done by all the global
coverages of other portals and I have
all the National Data so if you're
looking for National Data you say hey
I'm all going off to Cambodia what do I
have please go look at my site it's
broken down by everywhere in the world
it's got other any soils data that I
think is online by every three months I
I
so what are the issues
okay so you you're here and you are you
want to use Global soil hands
well as I said poor accuracy and high
uncertain so the fact of the matter is
there's a lot we don't know about soil
cover right so we need lesser in a
really do a really detailed survey these
maps are they give you an idea
it's better than nothing but even if you
know and we so we have that and why
incomplete distribution of points and
features folks meaning there are areas
of the world that we uh environments let
me say that we've hardly sampled or that
we don't have the data available some
combination of environmental factors
where we haven't gone and see those seen
that data
um the calibration points can be
incompatible or outdated
they can be in the wrong place
so I had this happen to me when I went
to Uganda once and went to the farm
there and the Americans had gone there
and taken a few points that were in our
database back in the 1980s before Bill
Clinton turned off the uh selective
reneability on the GPS so I navigated to
the points
and this is a by the way this is the
exact place where the Katina concept was
developed by Mill in the 1930s with this
beautiful regular landscape in the
Kampala area of Uganda and his very
regular landscape you have the parts of
the soil pouring a chain called the
Katina so I'm standing there and I said
this can't be right
and we went down to the village and we
found the retired technician who was
quite an old man by this point who had
uh worked with the Americans when they
were there I said can you take us to the
site he said sure So he said okay they
were here and as soon as I stand there I
think it definitely this is correct I
can see from the soil description this
is the right site so I corrected the
four GPS points I took a proper GPS once
I went back to the Netherlands and we
corrected them in the database that's
four points of the many thousands and
thousands that are up it was off by
about 200 meters because the GPS was not
so accurate back then and you were a
completely different position in this
beautiful Hillside Catina so it's am I
trying not to correlate it with the
elevation the slope or whatever I'm in
the wrong place so my model is going to
be bad because the soil is not where
it's supposed to be so that's one of our
big problems
um
and we're now working on the derived
properties of soil functions
um so these are the future developments
what we really want we want more
covariates that are more related to soil
formation and we'd really like to Now
work on properties that are more useful
directly to you so instead of saying
sand seal and Clay what's a hydraulic
conductivity you know what's the thermal
what's the thermal conductivity I was
mentioning the work that was done in
sunshine University
and then the idea of communicating
uncertainty we'd like to be better at
telling people don't like uncertainty
but we want to tell them you probably
shouldn't use this map or or depending
on what your purpose is
so that's it thanks for your attention
I can repeat the question okay okay
uh it's one of our talk I'd like to
thank you very much for providing those
products my love have a YouTube several
of your
productsd and also soil grade
yeah so so
it wasn't any you talked about without
my sleeping kids and uh there was uh you
know the important issue and you're
you're not addressing and
you mentioned that probably we need more
data more completed information despite
that are the other other ways to adjust
that considering the issue you know that
if I understand correctly your soil grid
2.0
after you use machine learning ask where
you get like 0.64 is that right well it
depends on the price each so the
question is how how accurate is the
overall r squared or accuracy well
that's per property so each property
will have we'll have a different one
they're in that in that rate yes
still like 30 36 percent of their
availability kind of explain uh do we
have a way to you know to understand
those variability right well the
question is how can we how can we reduce
the error and what are the methods one
point as I mentioned if some of that
error remember that's a global average
so some errorism areas might be
predicted better than other areas some
of that number is coming from areas we
put it very badly because we don't have
any representation of that place in the
future space so for example we had very
few in in the polar environments the
surfer polar environments so we were
getting a lot of uncertainty there
because we that combination of the
temperature precipitation Frost periods
and everything else we didn't have soils
points that represented that environment
that's one the other one is getting and
here's where I am working on
we are very poor at representing certain
Souls on according factors and the most
obvious one is time
soils form over time
this area in southern Germany that has
got tropical soils they're Relic
tertiary soils in this area near Munich
that you would never predict from the
current temperature and and conditions
there and we have paleosols that are
exhumed Iowa is famous for this you have
you know you have these you have
previous glaciation of soils that were
weathered that are now being and we have
nothing that helps us really get the
time
so I don't know what covariance we might
use so that's I think we're missing
we're missing things and then there yeah
I'd say that's one of the main main
things that we are trying to include
covariance I don't think the machine
learning methods are the limitation
I think with better covariance and
better data than machine learning would
not be uh would not be implementation
although you can always try to improve a
little bit
anyone so thanks for the question yeah I
have a question about how current remote
sensing products the movie future
products are helping inform covariance
particularly with land cover
um although at the same time we know
that the time series behind this product
from social
how do you how have they been leveraged
and where do you see the new
developments coming in that space
yeah the question is with the remote
sensing products we have more and more
how would we be leveraged you make very
good point actually we now have a longer
time series so for things like
agricultural life or land that's managed
if you have a 20-year time series that
has not been exploited too well to try
for example things like carbon things
like bulk density could somehow relate
that then
to but you would then need the soil
observations at those different times so
that's when we haven't we haven't tried
yet
there is a lot more Precision in the
Community but um yeah I think some of
the sensors
they're like all I I should have put her
name in Laura buggio is our main digital
soil mapper at district and she's
actively looking for these new
covariates and the new remote sensing
products are part of that but
yeah the time series is is quite
interesting you know how to say more
than that
we have a good good to win yeah well we
won one time I didn't one last question
yeah okay yeah you okay okay because I
know Joseph Joseph can talk to me later
[Music]
there are some levels
are looking at
it
self space foreign
[Music]
that's a really good point so the
question was could we for two things one
one was about the the spectron the the
satellite spectroscopy so let me answer
that one first
we use lab spectroscopy now on deeply
and there is a live relational that's
only the top soil that who knows if we
really get those we can now start using
some of the models we've calibrated in
the lab we saw a property that might
really be helpful for certain things in
the in the in the soil we get the
spectroscopy the satellite spectross
second one is if we knew the new the
land cover the biotype and I hadn't
thought of that that's a really good
idea because you know if you you see
different land covers will have really
big influence on the soil problems
around here we have the famous Red Pine
plantations that were put up
by the CCC to recover Farmland but they
acidify the soil horribly and kill
everything around it and if you say
there's a red pine Plantation your pH is
going to be I don't know how low but you
you would make that correlation that's a
really nice Point thanks for thanks for
bringing that up
more about it
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu